das ist eine sehr angespannte szene wie
wenige polizisten dort mehreren
hunderten demonstranten gegenüberstehen
und über diese szenen wollen wir
sprechen mit konstantin von notz
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der grünen herzlichen guten morgen herr
von notz und auch an sie erstmal die
frage was empfinden sie bei diesen
bildern gestern vor dem reichstag einen
herzlichen guten morgen so wie ich
glaube das war extrem bittere bilder die
wir da
bei gesehen haben und das hätte nicht
passieren dürfen
und natürlich muss man sowohl für die
3000 beamtinnen und beamten die gestern
am wochenende im einsatz waren in berlin
um die demonstrationsfreiheit
unseren rechtsstaat und eben auch das
parlament zu schützen aber insbesondere
den dreien die dort auf den letzten
treppenstufen standen extrem dankbar
sein und ich habe da eine volle
anerkennung für diesen offensichtlich
großartigen einsatz den sie geleistet
haben
wann diese bilder das was wir da jetzt
eben sehen können der preis für unsere
versammlungsfreiheit
ja ich glaube so kann man jetzt nicht
sagen man muss immer sehen der
historische kontext des
reichstagsgebäudes ist hoch aufgeladen
mit unserer deutschen geschichte das
dort gestern bereich fahnen geschwenkt
wurden
das ist ein massives problem auch wegen
der bilder aber gegen der bedeutung die
eben solche symbole wie das parlament
auch haben und ich glaube wir müssen in
zeiten in denen in belarus menschen für
freiheit und demokratie auf die straße
gehen und wenn sie jetzt im parlament
die ihnen streiten die für freiheit
demokratie und wenn man in einem
rechtsstaat in der bundesrepublik
deutschland in sturm auf berlin
organisiert wenn man versucht des
reichstagsgebäudes die sturm dann stellt
man sich eben gegen freiheit und
demokratie
dann steht man für das gegenteil zu
diktatur und tyrannei und deswegen es
ist ganz wichtig dass wir aus diesem tag
gestern auch lernen und unsere
rechtsstaat und den rechtsstaat und
demokratie noch wehrhafte aufstellen
glauben sie herr von rotz dass es hin
und her um das verbot der demonstration
im vorfeld diesem tag dann eher noch
mehr aufmerksamkeit mehr demonstranten
und jahr mehr feuer gebracht hat ach ich
weiß nicht ich bin jetzt auch niemanden
in schutz nehme ich glaube man sollte
wirklich ganz genau analysieren was
gestern passiert ist wie gesagt die
beamtinnen und beamten vor ort die dort
am wochenende für unsere demokratie im
einsatz bin denen kann man nur dankbar
sein über die strategie die da gestern
angewandt wurde bei einer veranstaltung
bei der das motto auch war sturm auf
berlin
muss man mal eine genaue fehleranalyse
machen ob man da gut aufgestellt war
auch um solche szenen die wir jetzt
diskutieren zu verhindern
dass demonstrationen nicht genehmigt
werden sollen dass das vor gerichten
entschieden wird das ist eigentlich
alltäglich und insofern ob das die eine
besondere verschärfung bedeutet hat ich
glaube es fast nicht aber auch das
sollte man genau analysieren aber diese
auseinandersetzungen in einem
rechtsstaat von der unabhängigen justiz
entschieden werden
das ist eigentlich alltagsgeschäft und
das muss man ja auch mal sagen wo aller
bigotterie diejenigen die dort
demonstrieren gehen gegen die
vermeintliche tyrannei in unserem land
gegen ein regime das unterdrückt jenen
dann vor unsere unabhängige gerichte und
kriegen ihre demonstration genehmigt und
es gibt eben meinung bei unserem land
und darauf bin übrigens auch stolz sein
letzte frage noch ein sie herr von notz
wir haben ja gestern und auch heute
versucht zu analysieren was für menschen
dort auf die straße gehen es war ein
recht bunter mix von
verschwörungstheoretikern
rechtsradikalen aber eben auch normalen
bürgern die einfach zweifel oder skepsis
gegenüber den chor ohne regeln haben
können die sich jetzt noch rausreden
dass ihnen nicht klar mit wem sie dort
auf die straße gehen
also erstmal ist es das gute recht in
unserem land und wir sind ein
rechtsstaat gesetz eine demokratie sein
unmut kundzutun und ich glaube wir
diskutieren doch alle die krone regeln
jede familie jeder freundeskreis über
all das diskutiert
wobei man einfach sagen die zustimmung
in der bevölkerung von den allermeisten
demokratischen parteien zu den maßnahmen
der bundesregierung in dieser pandemie
sind enorm hoch
es gibt eine enorm hohe zustimmung und
deswegen natürlich muss man gespräche
offen sein und man muss auch verständnis
haben
wie weit kann es passt dass eben gesagt
hat es gibt menschen die sind in ihrer
existenz bedroht und sie haben große
sorgen und die wollen sie zum ausdruck
bringen dass ich vollkommen richtig
gesetzt haben sie von wolfgang bosbach
angesprochenen unbestimmten
rechtsbegriffe diesen hilfspaketen auch
als opposition scharf kritisiert und
dürften es gibt auch dinge gegen die man
demonstrieren kann und über die man
unmut äußern kann
aber wenn eben mit symbolen aus der
nazizeit gegen unseren freiheitlich
demokratischen rechtsstaat mobilisiert
wird dann muss man eine klare linie
ziehen und mit diesen leuten die darf
man nicht marschieren wenn antisemiten
unterwegs sind
wenn gegen das vermeintliche welt
judentum gehetzt wird all das ist auch
vor dem historischen kontext unseres
landes unerträglich und der muss man
eine ganz klare linie die grünen
politiker konstantin von notz vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch und
ihre zeit
ich danke ihnen in einem schönen konter
ihnen auch danke sehr